- Jetzt du!
Ich dachte, du boxt zum ersten Mal?
- Ich boxe auch zum ersten Mal.
- Dafür muss das Säckchen
aber ganz schön einstecken!
- Ja, ich hab' in meiner Kindheit nicht
mit Puppenhäuschen gespielt.
Ich war mit den Jungs unterwegs.
Da wird man nicht zimperlich.
- Wo bist du denn aufgewachsen?
- Im Ruhrpott.
- Da wurde viel Steinkohle für die
Industrie abgebaut, oder?
- Ja, dafür ist das Gebiet besonders
bekannt.
Während der Industrialisierung
hat es angefangen
und danach verwandelten sich die
ganzen kleinen Städtchen nach und nach
während des wirtschaftlichen
Umschwungs in Großstädte ...
- Mehr Kraftwerke, mehr Arbeiter.
- Ja. Und je mehr Arbeiter,
desto mehr Arbeiterjungs,
die frech werden konnten.
- Wann bist du von dort weggezogen?
- Äh, als ich mit dem Studium
angefangen habe.
Das Ruhrgebiet hat seinen Charme,
aber es sind alles Arbeiterstädte.
Und die sind alle nicht besonders schön.
- Ja, im Krieg wurde viel bombardiert, oder?
- Ja, ich beklage mich auch nicht.
Ich sage nur, dass es schönere Orte gibt.
- Wie spät haben wir's?
- Äh, keine Ahnung.
- Kannst du mir dein Auto leihen?
- Ja, klar.
- Ja?
- Ja.
Äh, warte!